[Music]
if we take two solutions one acidic and
the other alkaline and mix them what
will be the result by now you should be
able to answer that it will give us a
salt and water will be released as a
by-product is it and an alkali always
give us salt and water yes it will
always be like this
an acid when combined with the base will
always give us salt and water and what
does this reaction call does it have a
specific name yes it does
it's called a neutralization reaction
here the strength of both the acid and
the base are lowered they are brought to
a neutral point where the intensity of
the acid as well as the base are dropped
lower the best example to study a
neutralization reaction is the formation
of sodium chloride or simply put common
salt if we take hydrochloric acid and
combine it with sodium hydroxide then
the neutralization reaction gives us
sodium chloride and water is obtained as
a by-product
the reaction also liberates a lot of
energy in the form of heat this is how
every neutralization reaction works acid
and a base combine to give salt and
water with heat generation but looking
at the reaction of sodium chloride
formation you may say that
neutralization only occurs in
laboratories when acids and bases are
combined in a test tube in a lab it's
only then a neutralization process
occurs is that the case actually that's
not the case neutralization reactions
are a part of our daily lives as well
many reactions occurring inside a body
or even throughout the day are
neutralization reactions for example we
usually find elders complaining about
acidity or ants biting us on the skin
these are examples where the person
of acid increases in sight or on the
body compared to the normal value such
cases are treated with medicines but
have you wondered how these medications
work needless to say they were based on
the principle of neutralization next
let's have a glance at the various
examples of neutralization reactions in
everyday life
[Music]